and that leads us to our draft for this
Monday edition of PFT live at dominant
NFL athletes of the last 20 years Chris
I've got the trivia question if you get
it right you pick first
today is Ben Roethlisberger's 38th
birthday there are two other
quarterbacks from Big Ben's 2004 draft
class that are still active in the
National Football League one obviously
is Philip Rivers who is the other
quarterback from the 2004 draft class
who is still playing whoa okay don't
google it I see you know I'm not my
hands are here hold on I debt that is
this is gonna drive me crazy actually
that I get this wrong I'm going I'm
looking at the team's real quick mm I
could get two I give you a hint but it
would give it away we're not counting
Eli Manning right that doesn't care he's
retired who am i nice for watching the
show that you're on I am going to miss
something oh my gosh who is it go ahead
tell me it's Matt Shaw gosh day huh who
I mentioned in a text message to you
within the last hour you're right you
did holy cow I can't believe I miss you
that's the thing if I had said if I had
said I mentioned him in a text message -
yeah that would have been too much too
much that's good I'm glad I got it wrong
that's got it service I get I get the
first pick and I don't want to give in
to recency bias
I gotta go Mike Vick Mike Vick is the
best you know he just everything he
could do the speed the just the way he
moved his body I don't care that he
wasn't one of these guys he could have
played three or four different sports he
could have if he wanted to
that guy was head and shoulders above
everyone else athletically on the
football field
when he split the Vikings defense in the
overtime game in 2002 and a couple of
Vikings defensive players clanged into
each other I knew we were dealing with
an athlete that we had never seen before
at the NFL level and there it is right
under your whip but do you guys have all
like the bad Vikings game b-roll just
like ready to press a button the answer
I'm hearing from stats is yes but that
you know and and the other thing too we
were talking about last week asking the
guys
at the at the combine who they are gonna
be most in awe of when they show up in
the NFL and so many of them said Tom
Brady and it's kind of like that's kind
of like how Mike Vick was went when he
joined the Eagles in 2010 there were
guys in the locker room who were in awe
because they they idolized mike vick and
everything he could do so i think mike
vick when we talk about athletic ability
the most dominant player the last 20
years yeah I mean I hear you there I do
he's certainly in that that realm for me
no doubt about it I mean watching him in
person seeing the things he did had a
rocket left arm but his speed Mike it
just and again Lamar Jackson he's really
special all right don't get me wrong I
don't think Lamar Jackson straightaway
was is as fast as michael vick michael
vick and the games i was on the field
with him was the fastest guy on the
field and i was a part of the tampa bay
buccaneers team that was known to be
fast at the time I mean we were small
and fast and Michael Vick was the
fastest of the group so I'm with you
there all right I'm gonna go a little
different route here I'm gonna go with a
defensive lineman I'm going with Aaron
Donald all right Aaron Donald for me is
it still the best defensive player in
the year I know I noted Stephon Gilmore
won Defensive Player of the Year this
year and all that stuff but come on you
know we know that goes a little bit with
the win-loss record the team - Aaron
Donald's still the best defensive player
in this league he's so dominant and then
yeah I'm gonna give him like props I
mean a 285 pounds he ran for six eight
he bench press you know - 25 35 times
put on a number of other unbelievable
you know feats as far as the combine is
concerned but this is like a
first-ballot Hall of Fame legend already
and he's like not even at the halfway
point of his career yet and still going
strong you know I've never seen anything
like it and it just continues to be
really dominant and awesome so I'm
putting Aaron Donald in that greatest
athletes I've seen over the last 20
years you know I had Russell Wilson
higher on the list than my my second
pick cuz Russell Wilson is a baseball
player and you know we see his athletic
ability on the football field but I
gotta go Kyler Murray I mean Tyler
Murray is a guy who was the number one
overall pick in the NFL Draft and a
top ten pick in the Major League
Baseball Draft he could have waltz right
into baseball they had to talk him into
playing football and I don't think he
would have played football they didn't
think he was gonna be the number one
overall pick the guy's incredible we had
Kliff Kingsbury last Tuesday raving
about what this guy can become I firmly
believe that he can take the NFL by
storm in 2020 the way that Patrick
mahomes did in 2018 and Lamar Jackson
did in 2019 and he played so much more
as a rookie than either of those guys
and he went largely unnoticed because
his team struggled this guy is
phenomenal he can move he can run he's
fast he's agile the ball explodes off of
his hand the ball explodes into the
hands of the receiver I held in
hindsight I should have made it my first
pick but Cuyler Murray second round pick
for me yeah you probably should have
that was a mistake by you know I got
both off about it a great athlete and
there's no doubt about it I mean he is
anything that's you know not only he's
rare because he's a great athlete that
also is a skillful athlete you know
that's the you know the argument a lot
of the times what makes a great athlete
right this is a guy who's really fast
and can jump you know really far and
jump high and do all that you know I
know guys like that but then like if you
see them dribble a basketball you go
have you ever been on a basketball court
before you watch them throw a football
and you go whoa can't even throw are you
throwing with the right arm is that the
right arm you're throwing with you know
so what is that or where is the athlete
the guy who's you know can play golf can
hit ten-foot jumpers all day long on a
basketball court you know can throw a
ball do all that Kyle Murray is a great
blend of both and that's where where
he's kind of special that way all right
I'm going to a guy I mean come on his
nickname is Megatron okay it's frickin
Megatron when you get named after a
machine that usually okay I had the
experience of going down to Georgia Tech
the year after I lost my spleen and
throwing to Calvin Johnson and he
probably got done with that workout was
like man I hope Tampa doesn't draft me
that guy can't throw because I couldn't
throw I was throwing ducks everywhere
Mike and this guy was like spider-man or
like Inspector Gadget it was like go-go
gadget arms I was throwing them ducks 12
feet in the air and he was just snagging
them down and ripping him out of the air
and kept running but I mean 6 5 - 37 for
35 and the 40 I mean are you insane and
really it's those attributes that what
ended his career because humans aren't
intended to be that big and to be able
to do that explosive which eventually
wore down his knees and ended him and
ended up being the demise of his career
but to me that he will always go down as
one of the greatest physical specimens
I've ever seen and one of the greatest
athletes in the history of the NFL I I
was at his last college game Georgia
Tech West Virginia in what was called
the Gator Bowl at the time he was
unstoppable in the first half and you
know it was kind of like when West
Virginia faced Larry Fitzgerald
eventually realized the only thing you
can do against guys like that is just
get to the quarterback and put him on
his butt before he can throw the ball
and that's what happened in the second
half of a game against Pitt when Larry
Fitzgerald was dominating West Virginia
and that's what happened in the second
half of that game the production went
down because the ball wasn't getting out
but he was unstopped was obvious from
the second day of what was Alltel
stadium at the time that this guy is
special and he would go on to be very
special all right next one for me let's
go to the defensive side of the ball
let's go with a guy who was not only the
sixth man on the University of North
Carolina basketball team good pick in
the draft am you a giant and a freak of
nature Julius Peppers a guy that you
know very well from your time with the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers haven't you told
the story about you walk up to the line
and you see Julius Peppers and you just
kind of pee a little bit yeah I Peter
first off he he abused us and Tim and
watch I mean he had like four plays in a
row one year you can see we couldn't
block him okay and yeah I used to pull
out underneath the center and start
looking behind my back because I was
like I know he's coming he's gonna be
here any second look I'm looking at him
like damn it was him again but but nope
the story is this Mike I'm playing it
Texas it's my junior year and I run out
to middle of the field right you're
gonna throw Pat and go to the receivers
and Julia's peppers is right there and I
looked at them and I was like holy you
know bad word holy bad word high go no
wonder I go I can't believe you're Julia
you're yeah I was like I yelled it up
and he laughed at me he thought I was
crazy cuz you're a frickin nature no
wonder you're so awesome and then I just
turned around and kept warming up
but we always what's amazing in those in
those highlights and and this is why I'm
always shocked and I remember like the
first time I met Boomer Esiason or Dan
Marino I didn't realize how big they
were or a giant but guys like that make
you look small numbers makes you look
like an average dude ya know and you're
a freaking giant yeah here it is again
yeah yeah you just you hey I think I
think you took a dive there go I think
Jim Rome would call you Chris anyway
well yeah good Jim Rohn he could call me
Chris that's my name anyways I will
throw a punch though if he wants to be
continued but yeah I was always worried
about him and I was always worried about
having the ball out or dangling because
I felt like if he came around and hit me
I was gonna lose you know lose the
football and but oh my gosh yes that's a
great call by you I didn't think you
would remember him and I was gonna take
him with my next pick and now I'm
scrambling here okay I you know I
thought about Dwight Freeney
right because he did an amazing he was
amazing I'm gonna go with Adrian
Peterson though just flat out I mean
Adrian Peterson come on this to me is
one of the three greatest running backs
in the history of football you know in a
220 pounds and I know you know last
twenty years we're talking about
greatest athletes and the combine and
being relevant there but you know to run
for 41 to have a 38-inch vertical you
know and to be built the way he is to
have the career he's having and let's
like let's be serious now Adrian
Peterson is a car-crash running back and
he's still looking for more core crashes
here and you're what the hell year is
this for him Mike twelve I don't even
know anymore
it doesn't matter thirteen that's insane
14:07 that is acts unbelievable but to
me he is one of the greatest specimens I
have ever seen and as you know I've told
that story many times the first time I
saw him in person
I went whoa the NFL's got freaks and
then there's Adrian Peterson he was an
another level in the prime of his career
you know I got to go with one audible
mention as well and this is a nod to
Tristan worse and Makai Becton two very
large men yeah who we saw moving very
nimbly Vince Wilfork oh that's what
Goodwin I mean the guy could run the guy
kitchen
remember that hard knocks they did he's
out there draining the jumpers and
that's to be an effective nose tackle
you have to have a lot of size but
you've got to be very strong and very
nimble you got to be able to slice
through the center in the guard and you
have to be able to use that that size as
effectively as possible and move and he
could and it's just comical when my son
and I used to play Madden back when my
kid was like 10 11 years old he would
always crack up at Vince Wilfork
especially when they were in the white
uniform because he was just so big but
he could move yeah and that's what made
it even funnier and even more impressive
yup he could move I mean as we know he
gave me Lakers private parts and
Baltimore Ravens colored private parts
one time he could about that he put his
helmet right into my pelvis but yes
those guys don't get noticed enough as
their ability but you know I you know
him I thought about saying Barclay yeah
you thinking about my Lakers man it was
like the LA Lakers it was you know but
yeah I thought about him JJ Watt was
another guy to this conversation who
deserves to be in that Byron Jones I
mean come on the guy set the world
record in the broad jump the world
record not the combine record and the
whole freaking world he did it at the
combines so those were a few others that
just jumped out to me
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports